Click on the timestamp in the
description to skip this intro,
then read the comment section of people asking
for the timestamp to skip this intro.
Firstly, huge announcement: Bob Lazar has donated
Element 115, and I heard that Jeremy Corbell
is working to stretch this 10 minutes of
content into a 3 and a half hour documentary.
Personally, I’m looking forward to it being
narrated by Mickey Rourke because I don’t
think I have enough thoughts of “what the f**k is
going on” already floating around in my head.
Secondly, there will be new thumbnails. Out with
the old clean images, and in with the cutouts of
Curt in a provocative pose with a guest, and the
contrived white borders with the red arrow, since
that’s not overplayed on YouTube. Why not
achieve the equivalent of mind uploading,
and give my soul to the algorithm?
In that vein, I’m going to make sure to say LIKE
this video, and SMASH that subscribe button. Call
to actions. Ending videos with "So, What do you
guys think? Leave a comment below about something
vapid that wastes everyone’s time, for the sake
of demonstrating engagement to the platform.”
More REACTIONS to memes with guests. I think that
the popularity of the stand alone meme clips more
than justifies the degradation of the character
and self-respect they bring to a channel.
We’ll also have different TYPES of reaction
videos, so for example. Sabine Hossenfelder
REACTS to Eric Weinstein trying to explain
a point without jargon and irritation that
people aren’t understanding that the GIN is
a sensemaking smooth structure on a fiber
bundle over the space of the twin nuclei
problems of the Shiab operator’s pullback of
the N^2 Revolution’s Russel conjugated...
Linda Moulton Howe REACTS to Curt’s
leather jacket.... Leo Gura REACTS
to... antipsychotic medication.
Also, for every 1 podcast I’ll snip
about 6 clips of it and post it to the
main channel to increase view counts,
at the expense of cluttering your feed because
you don’t necessarily need to associate quality
with every single post on this channel. That’s
ridiculous. You can skip it if you don’t like,
I mean you can skip everything except the patreon
and the sponsor messages requests, which will
remain approximately 40% of the video.
Another announcement is that there will more
pushback from Curt. Especially toward the guests
who repeatedly admit that their interpretation
of quantum mechanics is not testable, and
that the data that they have is anecdotal,
about something perhaps there’s an NDA involved,
with me repeatedly saying, “Okay well, where’s
the evidence!?” And then smugly lean back,
as they admit in self defeat “Ah, Curt wow,
you got me! What a brilliant question that I’ve
never considered before” I will then follow suit
with a liberal use of the word “grifter”
and writhe in my own self-importance
anonymously on social media.
Another announcement for the Ask Me
Anythings, the more sober and ordinary
the username, the better.
AlienAlcoholic asks “have you heard of facilities
that are housing live aliens.” This question
comes from Poop Dig, What does he think, (I
know). This question comes from Dom Telonge.
Question to Ross from Euphoric_Gur_4674, as a
journalist who understands...Where do you get
all these names? And of course, priority will
be given to AlienSmegmaCollector - which by the
way I just found out is Mick West’s
pseudonym on Animal Crossing.
On this theme, if you want to hear what
the other theolocution guest has to say,
then you’re going to have to pay for a
premium subscription. “People are always like
Superdeterminism isn’t the thing, and they never
bother to look at the literature, um to see what
models people have actually worked with.”
[Inaudible chattering from Charlie Brown]
Recently I’ve come to several conclusions:
* Like that the fringe is indeed misinformed
and the innovation will come from the conservative
center. On this account I think String Theory is
probably correct. Many Worlds is probably correct.
That Area 51 picture of an alien is indeed
genuine. I think real aliens
show evidence of polygon edges,
and clearly pixelated texture maps.
I’ve also realized that I need to stop
smiling so much, it's a bit off putting to the
guests to be so welcoming and amiable.
[Oh Fortuna]
I’m also going to
be ramping up the amount that I say "this podcast
is technical" 4 times in the same 3 minute video,
because I don’t think my introductions are
stilted, and verbose, and pompous enough.
“The first hour can be rather technical” In these
podcasts we tend to delve into intricacies, and
equations, sometimes meticulous technicalities”
If you’ve surveyed this channel before,
as we’ve done an unduly technical dive
into Donald Hoffman’s papers...
Also, to reflect the UFO content, TOE will be
rebranded as UF TOE, and logos will be changed
to a picture of myself phlegmatically staring
at the camera. It is, after all, all about me
and not the subject: “I ♥️ Curt”.
Lastly, there will be more me pensively
looking off onto my desk, at some unseen object as
if I’m silently having a profound insight but I'm
truly thinking about if my poor wife has used up
the plastic cups we set aside for her to urinate
in because this is the only bathroom in our condo
and I’m 4 hours into this podcast live.
You know what? I don't think I’ve imitated
Jordan Peterson’s mannerisms enough this year,
so I’ll be working on that as well.
Thank you, and I hope you enjoy the upcoming
changes. Now hold on, while I observe the chat
explaining to people that Premiering isn’t the
same as Live Streaming.
*
This podcast is now finished, if you’d
like to hear me supplicate for another
few seconds then continue listening to my
100% not repetitive plead for donations.
It’s support from the patrons (AKA: The
Splendid and Munificent) and the sponsors
(AKA: Those brave enough to invest
in a channel on mathematical physics,
consciousness, and God teetering as close as
you can to being Deepak Chopra without being
Deepak) that allow me to do this full time.
Every dollar helps tremendously. Thank you.